oh my god take that minigun - it's not
exactly torture if I have a minigun that
is sadistic that reflects some dark
parts of my soul I know that for sure
not torture this is the opposite of the
intention of torture I'm gonna do it
again because I'm a sadist apparently
that guy at the bottom though don't even
think about looking
why am I making a sound effect when the
game is doing it cuz I don't know how to
live otherwise
our poon run I'm not ready my mic is all
off okay use the up key got it
[Music]
I feel good about life okay oh god just
ended my I didn't expect death to be
like that just do it do it okay I'm
gonna try I'm gonna try to do double
whammy I got double whammy KaBlam eed
alright enough baby talk let's just do
it
just ethics around every corner combo
that kept me in the air for just long
enough for me to experience hell
something tells me this is gonna be a
bridge Menards the rest of my pelvis and
also lungs heart spleen liver pancreas
intestines and brain oh it counts I'm
even in a praying mantis squatting
position not that that helps anything
I'm still gonna be pinned here until I
bleed out and die but hey I got a coin
reverse I don't know
you said reverse matrix they just came
from behind it's not the same thing
haha
I won by humping who knew dead guy cap
that is not a jet guy unless he's really
a daredevil
oh boy one of these huh oh god I'm never
good at peace fail come on good great
oh boy someone's happy with my here we
go son that's gonna be bonkers that's
gonna be a boggy Walker's we're not
going to okay let's fly with the cheese
oh okay God got exactly what I deserved
Oh horrible sweet death number fo
alrighty then how about a little bit of
Yolo to your leaf ah miss me dick bag
[ __ ] you okay alright super jet pack
SuperSpeed jet pack 13 make level dark
make jetpack invisible alright here we
go then i pressing the button why isn't
my eyes button or do where's the button
oh do avoid the dot see good thing I do
these dots are horrible but I can't
avoid them because I am so smart
probably not oh my poor buttocks Oh
Frick like being pulled into a black
hole oh [ __ ] oh god just get back here
you bastard I just want to grab it
Tom jaha it's very consistent my failure
there we go oh wow there we go
[Music]
Olga versus hard tip don't use oh that's
why death approaches hello I'm already
gone thank you okay happiness is my name
I failed their point it does not matter
how many you shove into my urethra this
has been happy wheels highlights thanks
for watching if you want to see more
happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye